Don't have flowers, do
n't talk
[Applause]
Smile in the corner of your heart Don't
break it,
don't let it end
Even now, the melody wo
n't disappear
[Applause]
I can't cry well It's
painful
I want to scream
It doesn't matter
[music]
[applause]
I was looking at the
sun A
long
time ago on a
chilly day
A bouquet of flowers that disappeared into the sky
Standing by the sea
Your dazzling profile Your
innocence was
too innocent to say anything It's
past
I'm drowning in self-answers I
've done more, even
though I can't go back
[music]
Don't see me,
don't let go
I'll play the continuation of the candida song from that time
here
Even now, the melody that wo
n't disappear
[music] The
days when I cried too much
, the memories of the two of us that melted away We broke down the memories of the two of us again,
laughing at the promises we joked
about Words I shouldn't have said to you
Don't let it come true, don't
let go of that day You forgot the smell and temperature that you left behind
Clouds
[music]
Desire
and what happened to the sea I'll
sing the continuation of the song here In a
city without
you tomorrow without you
[Music] The
melody
[Music] My
heart is similar to reality If I keep it
loose, it won't make a sound Until I'm on the
verge of tearing It's
painfully pasted
[Music] For the
first time, it's the sound that shakes my eardrums